alright thanks folks thanks for this
stay sticking with us through the
afternoon
it's April 20 it's a little bit after
4/20 now I was actually thinking I
should change my job to something about
like THC contradict concentration
analysis but we're gonna do something
just as fun we're gonna play minecraft
and just before I get into it I'm just
gonna jump in and make sure nothing is
going to sleep on me while we've been
getting ready like Minecraft servers
running I'm gonna connect over into our
and make sure I can connect to it and by
the way that is my IP address for my
minecraft server if you want to go in
the world and troll me while I'm talking
feel free but let's start off with the
oily one thing I've did know it's
raining in the world I don't want that
let's stop it from raining where there
clear I think it's the command there we
go alright so let's start off fact let's
start off with the world so this is
minecraft I don't know if you've seen
minecraft if you have a teenage daughter
or son it's likely you have if not it's
just a fun open world environment you
can play in survival mode which means
that a bunch of zombies will come and
attack you I'm playing it in creative
mode which basically makes it into 3d
Lego and you can build all sorts of
structures and play around and dig and
in this particular case I've got a
little pumpkin here sitting on a stand
and if I hit that pumpkin nothing
happens because I forgot to run the
script let me go back up here that was
such an exciting demo I gonna put the
block back in the world and run a little
loop in ah which is gonna do some stuff
and there's my punchline alright there's
the block back and now when I hit the
block welcome to New York our conference
yeah
all right so I actually wanted to use
this to do all of my slides in Minecraft
but I got a bit lazy and I just have my
title slide but let let's talk a little
bit about it so like I said minecraft
it's a really fun 3d exploration and
building game if you have kids you've
probably seen it it was developed by
Mojang who was acquired by Microsoft in
2014 I point that out simply because it
gives me the justification for having
spent the last few days playing
Minecraft at work kids do amazing
amazing things with Minecraft they get
in the world and build all sorts of
things like this is the red keep in
westeros you know rendered in the
Minecraft world and they spent hours
upon hours upon hours doing this and
what we thought and particularly Carl
Broman who you can see over here thought
was why can we use this enthusiasm the
kids have for playing in the Minecraft
world and rather than building up a wall
brick by brick by brick
perhaps we can convince them to learn a
programming language namely ah so that
they could rather write a function to
build that wall for them and in the
process learn how to do programming so
at the our open site hackathon in Los
Angeles last year which was a really
really fun and awesome hackathon we got
together six of us to put together an
hour package with a bunch of simple
functions that kids could use to build
up more elaborate scenes and scenarios
and actions within the Minecraft world
this was inspired by a book that Cowell
had that he'd given to his daughter
could learn to program with Minecraft
which was based in Python and we thought
to give our rakul opportunity we should
create a similar kind of package in our
that will provide these functions for
kids to do these really cool things the
book provides a bunch of recipes for
doing all sorts of tasks like you know
build a staircase by writing a function
in Python and I'm going to show you how
you can do that same thing using these
packages in are the thing that makes all
this possible is the architecture of the
original Minecraft program where there's
a server that's running which basically
represents
the state of the world and in my car in
my case I'm going to be running that
server on a bunt to virtual machine
which is running in the cloud and then
there's a client which is what gives you
or the flashy graphics or flashy if you
consider those blocks to be flashy but
that's the thing that actually renders
the world for the point of view of the
player accepts the players motions and
commands and then sends those back to
the server which then updates the world
accordingly so the way our package in
our is going to work is it's going to
modify the world at the server side and
then it'll be rendered in the client
whose player when they're playing
Minecraft and you can do all this
yourself the server is open source it's
called spigot and you can download it
from all sorts of docker repositories
and I'll show you how to do that you do
require something called the raspberry
juice plugin which provides the API that
we're going to interface in from the odd
language you're also going to need the
minecraft program on your PC
unfortunately as thing stands right now
you can't use the Xbox or the mobile
versions you need to doubt and not the
Windows Store version but if you buy any
of those you also get access to the
original Mojang version which is a
java-based application and you need to
sign up for an account that no jane
don't come to do that but basically once
you've got everything set up you've got
the server running in a remote server
you've got the minecraft application
running on your desktop you've got a
third PC which in this case is going to
be the same as the one that are running
Minecraft on which is going to run these
packages I mentioned miner and Kraft
which are going to modify the world so
we've actually provided two packages to
do all this stuff the base package which
we put together at the our open site
hunk conference was called miner and
this provides very very simple building
blocks to interact with the server like
connect to the server through an IP
address have a look at the world by
seeing which blocks are rendered in
there available rather in the 3d world
and monitor the play so you can find the
location in the player which way they're
facing if they're hitting blocks all
that stuff is available as very basic
functions and that package is available
on github right now then for those sort
of high-level projects this idea
saying building a staircase we wrote a
separate package which encapsulates some
of these simple functions put together
the idea is that kids would write those
things themselves if they want to jump
right in and have some fun they can
access some higher-level functions which
are available in the craft package which
also has an Associated book which is
written in book down and they can sort
of go through all the steps of how these
higher-level activities were created and
learn along the way by having a look at
that book and a particular shade out
shout out to Kyle Broome and it put
together a lot of the content for that
book all right and in fact here's the
book there's the link where you can find
it and read it it's called our program
with Minecraft and you can see if you
have a look at the section on the left
hand side all the things you can do you
know build a staircase build a rainbow
build a tower plant a garden you know
all sorts of things that the kids might
want to have fun doing they can either
write themselves or just use the recipes
that are available in this book all
right now for you if you want to play
with all of this it's actually pretty
easy to get things set up one of the
things that is provided in the
instructions for the miner package is a
docker file if you haven't used docker
it's been mentioned a few times in the
talks today it's a really convenient way
of basically setting up all the
components in sort of a virtual machine
in this case that involves setting up
raspberry juice within spigot setting up
all the ports to open up the connections
to the minecraft server instead of doing
that manually just by using this docker
file you can then generate a server in
just a couple of seconds and all the
instructions are show you'd show you how
to do that are available in the miner
package all right in my particular case
I'm setting up the server as a virtual
machine within Asia and then rucking
running docker within that virtual
machine the specific virtual machine I
used to do that is something called the
data science virtual machine this is a
really handy collection of all sorts of
open source tools including things like
R and Python already set up in the
virtual machine but it also includes
some things that is particularly useful
for this project which is number one
docker itself which I used to run the
docker file which then loads in all of
the Minecraft stuff that I need and also
provides the
Mark's application which is really handy
for me when SSH drops the connection and
my minecraft server dives you'll see
that in a second when I get into it also
you might want to run this command in
spigot after you get things up things up
called default mode creative because
otherwise within a few minutes you'll be
overrun with zombies and all the work
you're doing is wasted alright so - once
you've got everything set up you've got
the server running in the cloud or even
on a local machine you can just install
those two packages from github so you
can use Hadleys dev tools package to
install them directly from github as you
can see there then use the miner library
this function NC connect connects our to
the running minecraft server and then
you can do su all sorts of things in
there and that's what you saw me do just
a second ago when I wrote a little
script called RC which is connect to the
server and read a little message so I
made sure all my connections are working
the connections do tend to expire for
about 10 minutes so you might see me
reconnecting if it's decided to
disconnect while I've been sitting here
chatting so there all sorts of functions
that are available to you in the craft
package - to modify the world based on
these sort of lower level functions just
to modify individual blocks for example
when you saw me pop up the message that
said welcome to NY our conference all I
did there was figure out where the
player was standing we had to get player
pause function and then used a couple of
functions that are available in the
craft package to write some text up in
space welcome to New York our conference
and having done that and because I'm in
creative mode I can sort of fly all
around the space you can see that these
are just blocks
they've been rendered in the 3d world
and you can kind of do anything you want
with them it's the rain back again
whether with clear
alright there we go alright so let's
have a look what else we can do
so with those funk that the basic
building blocks of those functions you
can do things like as we already seen
get the play position you can also set
blocks which means put things in the
world and there are different types of
blocks there's stone and there's wood
and there's ice in this glass and
there's gold and all sorts of things we
have a fun example which I meant to do
with Jared's photo and I didn't get
around to it in time but you can take
somebody's picture and then render it as
different colored blocks so you can
actually see the picture in the
Minecraft world that's kind of fun
here's another fun one you can actually
do this sort of dynamically as the
player is moving around in the world
just by using a while loop in the arc
function I'll show you how this works in
just a second so what I can do is I can
go into our I'm gonna have a look at my
scripts here I'm gonna put a couple of
blocks in the world just to give me a
starting point like I did before with
the pumpkin all right then I'm gonna run
a while loop which just has a look at
the block the player is standing on well
actually no sorry it's the while loop is
just to sit and watch
if the player triggers things might by
cutting a block but that little stat for
lip you can see right there what it's
doing is it's having a look at who's got
an error message up there and that's not
a see that's what happens when it
disconnects do that again
so I've ever turn an air that's not good
at all
this is fun watching we could live and
let's see what's happening in the world
alrighty house returned to normal
alright one more try and then I gotta
give up cuz this is really fun to watch
so let's set a couple of blocks in the
world so what should have happened at
that point is we have a block of ice
we're on top of a little blue block
there and we can wait for the player
district
while a man said do those things all
right now it's way that's thing I
destroyed the block too early because
what was supposed to happen was when I
click on this block it suddenly says you
have the power of Elsa and now what I
can do is as I run around the world and
as you can see there's a bit of water
over here as I get near the water all
right I give up what I was supposed to
do was it's really cool it was supposed
to like ice appears and drew feeds and
your Elsa and then you can stop it but I
give up if you want to see it later on
I'll be over there and you can see what
happens all right hopefully my other
demo works that's the fun one
all right one of the things you might
have seen was messages that popped up
they said you have the powers of L so
you can send messages to the players
with the chat post function you could
also grab the messages that the players
send between themselves with get check
posts because the players when they're
all in the world together often chat to
each other and that lets you do fun
things and this is in the craft book of
do things like you know number guessing
games you can say guess a number between
1 and 100 and all the players will type
different numbers and as soon as
somebody guesses the right number you
pull that out with chat posts and give
them a nice message and that's a fun
little game but the one I wanted to show
you was the one I've been playing around
with a couple last couple of days
justifying my work because this is a
Microsoft thing was to write a little
function in ah that would generate a
maze so I've got a function called Jen
maze it turned out there were actually a
couple of packages already on cran for
generating mazes in R but they're all
based on these old huge complicated you
will network algorithms
so whatever just run sprite something
simple that kids could do so I just went
back and did a simple recursive
generative maze function just the basic
computer science 101 and now when I have
these two functions I can do maze his
make maze 10 5 and you can see print
this amazing ASCII which isn't very
exciting but what I could do then is
render that maze in the Minecraft world
and we could play in the maze so let's
go back to my script here
so first thing I do is going to generate
a maze I'm gonna put there's altitude i
that is how high in the wood I want to
go and choose a couple of corners for it
I in a clear sense space in the world
alright so what we should find now is
when we look I'm still in the water over
here we've got some space cleared which
i think is gonna be over there yeah I
can see a big hole
alright am I going to add a floor for
the maze and then just loop through the
15 by 15 maze I created and put some
blocks on there alright there it is so
we can go over fly into the maze and now
let's see if I can solo this is a
randomly generated maze so I don't
actually know where to go and it
actually turns out like this isn't a
very big maze but I played with this a
bit and it's surprisingly difficult to
actually solve these when you can't look
from above which you can't actually do
function f5 there we go there we go I
can sort of look from above like this
and that makes things a bit easier but
more challenging would be is how can we
write a little robots that's gonna solve
that maze itself a little fun little
exercise so I just wrote a little
function which uses the left hand rule
to choose which way to go I won't go
through the details of this all of this
will be in my blog when I write it up
next week and then we can just write a
little thing that checks if it's fit
it's got to the end of the maze where I
put a torch just so you can see the end
and I will just follow the left-hand
rule as it moves around the world oh
it's decided it's sold it already all
right let's try it again now all right
oh my demo is failing this is so
embarrassing alright one more try and
let's it's all work but I tried it like
ten minutes ago so I literally alright
anyway come and come to the crypt of the
booth over there I'll be I can shoot all
that running but let's go to the end
all right so if you want to play around
this like I said it's all available
there on github at github calm RF in
Scilab slash miner the book is at the
link you can see on the screen right
there as well and that craft package
which implements the thing like doing
Elsa and the mazes is also available
that link right there and if you would
like to come and play online my server
is running now at the IP address you see
right there thanks very much
[Applause]
you